les discussions auront duré un an et
demi les intérêts communautaires sont
désormais votée à la quasi-unanimité un
soulagement pour l'ensemble des élus est
le fruit de longues négociations entre
majorité et opposition
il ya des moments où on va certains vont
plus loin que ce qui pouvait espérer en
prêtant mais d'autres moments il faut
savoir frais d donc c'est toujours un
compromis qu'il faut savoir retrouver
lorsque l'on doit arrêter sur des
intérêts communautaires
concrètement les 74 élus de saint
quentin en yvelines ont arrêté neuf
compétences dont 6 dites obligatoires
parmi celles ci la création et la
réalisation de zack ou encore l'ensemble
de la politique liée au logement plus
débattue elle les compétences
optionnelles comporte la gestion des
voiries et celle des équipements
culturels et sportifs le ciné 7 et le
prisme d'elancourt sortent des
compétences de l'agglomération la
piscine intercommunale de maurepas elle
n'y entre pas j'ai fait donc la
proposition avec mes collègues
d'elancourt et de coignières
voilà de ne plus transférer la piscine
de maurepas à saint quentin en yvelines
mais de négocier un fonds de concours
pour le sport et la culture
donc il y aura bien une piscine qui sera
intercommunale non pas communautaire
intercommunale construite par les trois
villes sur le territoire de maurepas
mais avec l'aide financière de 50 en une
au travers d'un fonds de concours en ce
nouvel outil financier pour la
construction de la nouvelle piscine sera
soumis au vote des élus à la fin du mois
de juin les intérêts communautaires
prendront eux effet à partir du 1er
janvier 2018